If you're only eating sugar, you're not getting the vitamins.
You're not getting the minerals.
You're not getting the essential fatty acids that you need.
You're not getting the protein that you need. Um,
we could debate whether or not you need fiber in the diet,
but we probably won't go there at the moment. Um,
so I'm gonna guess that within a reasonably short time, you're going to die.
The question is, can you survive, um, 30 days?
So Pete, would you be considered a sweet tooth?
Would I consider myself a sweet tooth?
I would say a little bit of, I would say yes and no.
I'm not one of those guys where you, after dinner, they're like, Hey,
what's for dessert. I would never order dessert. And I,
if somebody offered me cake or sweets or whatever, I probably wouldn't take it.
But if there's a bowl of candy on the table,
or if I'm in a store where there's chocolate bars, I'm,
I just can't get enough chocolate.
Never been known for my self discipline.
That wouldn't be something that would be on my, a Wikipedia page. If I had one,
uh, I've been known to, I have my kryptonite. So, you know,
I've been known to eat a cheesecake. For instance.
I ate cheese cake, a whole cheesecake slice, or you mean a slice. You,
you heard me.
But obviously we deal with hypotheticals here at what if,
and it does sound initially when you say,
what if you ate only sugar for a month? Well,
that's a wild hypothetical except for the period we're in
now, which is going to smack dab in the middle of that time,
where it's very possible for people to eat sugar every day,
which is of course the holiday.
Yeah,
this is when everybody is buying extra chocolate to put on the tables to hand
out, people are coming to your door. Here's just, here's some chocolate,
there's baked goods coming out of the oven,
seemingly every half hour in bowls of candy on every,
it's kind of a great thing.
It's a built-in excuse in which we loved.
So as a public service that we are doing for the word of community,
we thought we would ask what if you ate only sugar for a month?
And of course that isn't something that most people would have a lot of
knowledge about. And you would really want to talk to somebody who's,
who's really done a lot of research around the specific issue of sugar.
So we are very fortunate to be joined by the New York times.
Best-selling author of the case against sugar, Gary Taubes. Gary,
thanks for joining us today on what if discussion.
Gentlemen, thank you for having me.
So, uh,
as we talked about pros and cons of a 30 day sugar diet,
I'm going to guess the doll on a prose. We'll get to that in a second,
but let's get back to the Seminole book, the case against sugar.
What was your ultimate conclusion? Was sugar guilt.
Well, are you, I mean, my, the book, if you don't think so.
And I copped to that in the beginning, the argument I'm making in the book. So,
I mean, we've never had a period of our history where, you know,
Princeton's parents didn't think they had a ration, their, their children,
sugar consumption, right? So it's always,
there's always been this concept of too much. Sugar is always been out there,
but what does too much sugar do was the question and
what I'm addressing,
particularly as we have an epidemic of obesity and diabetes, worldwide,
whatever, any population,
the world transitioned from whatever their traditional diet is.
It could be anything from an agrarian diet and Southeast Asia to
a animal diet within you. And the, you know,
Mussai in Africa and they transitioned eating Western diets,
they get obese and diabetic. You have explosions of obesity and diabetes.
And the argument is that what happens is they just eat too much and they become
sedentary. And that's why you get these epidemics. And the,
the counter-argument is that it's sugar, particularly that causes it.
Not because of the calories in the sugar, but because of the, uh,
you could think of it as the hormonal effects of consuming sugar,
the way your body responds to sugar differently than other foods.
And, you know,
I just was lucky as a journalist or unlucky as a journalist,
I get to spend about 10 years of my life studying this question,
and it's clear that sugar should be considered uniquely harmful.
And then the way I put it, if I was a district attorney,
I could get an indictment effortless life.
I'm not sure I could get a conviction because we've never actually done the
studies that would allow you to say what I believe without, you know, with,
with outreach, winnable doubt.
Yeah. Like you, like you say, it does seem to be a bit of an open and shut case,
but if the jury is still out on sugar,
it's ultimately because of the inability to get more than circumstantial
evidence against the sweet stuff. Why is that?
Well, the conventional wisdom again, is that the problem was sugars.
We just eat too much of it to empty calories. You've all heard that phrase,
right? It's got empty calories.
So if you have a lot of sugar in your diet and you have to get the vitamins and
minerals and protein and fiber and essential fatty acids from other
foods, so then you're going to overeat those and you're going to get obese.
And once you get obese, that's going to be the trigger of your diabetes.
So there's this whole mindset in the book.
I refer to it as the gift that keeps on giving,
which is the reason you get fat is because you eat too much.
You take in more calories than you expend.
And the worst you could say about sugar is that we like it too much.
We're going to take a quick break here on what if discussed, uh,
more with the author of the case against sugar, Gary Taubes.
On the other side, you are watching and listening to if discussed.
We want to take just a moment to tell you about today's sponsor the great
courses, plus a.
Streaming service. We're both really big on.
Yeah, that's right. We've been watching and learning a lot during the pandemic.
I've been looking into a new course.
They've got online called mathematical brain teasers and logic puzzles.
You know, I love learning about other languages or like, you know,
about Ireland or photography was one of the one that I did.
But also sometimes I just want to stretch my brain out. And, uh, and uh,
I dunno, just go for a workout on my brain. Yeah. Good.
Brain workout. I'm a big puzzle person. Loved the jumble. Love the crossword.
Sudoku. No, not so much. It's just, I'm not a math person. It's not math.
It's just, it's one. I'm not a smart person. I'll give you some tips.
I've got some tips for you, uh, on Sudoku, regardless. The great courses,
plus has thousands of lectures on almost any topic imaginable from
astrophysics to learning to speak Spanish and new courses are coming up all the
time. There's something for everyone.
Plus every course is presented by experts from top universities and
institutions.
And you can watch or listen from your phone or your TV with the great courses
plus.
App, which helps me prepare for what if discussed. So for instance,
today, we were talking about what if you ate sugar for a month straight?
So where do I do my research? Great courses, plus.com,
how sugar and salt shape world history, lecture. Number 12,
from the course food science and the human body. They got everything here.
I'm glad you're doing all the research for this because if somebody got who
Peter, it does make a difference.
The great courses plus is offering fans of our show. This amazing deal,
an entire month of access free.
This limited time offer won't last long. Sign up today, go to the great courses
plus.com/whatever. Don't wait, go to the great courses.
plus.com/one F one more time. It's the great courses.
plus.com/one.
F. Now back to the show.
So Gary, you sort of outlined what happens to the body when you eat sugar,
what goes on inside you with all those [inaudible] happening? Uh,
but what if you only ate sugar for one month, for 30 days? That's our,
what if this week, uh, what would happen, Gary?
I can't imagine you'd be in great shape after 30 days.
If you're only eating sugar, you're not getting the vitamins.
You're not getting the minerals.
You're not getting the essential fatty acids that you need.
You're not getting the protein that you need. Um, they,
we could debate whether or not you need fiber in the diet,
but we probably won't go there at the moment. Um,
so I'm gonna guess that within a reasonably short time, you're going to die.
The question is, can you survive 30 days? Yeah.
And we don't recommend you try this.
At home and less,
obviously you're part of that experiment that Gary's talking about. Um,
Gary want to talk about a whole bunch more, especially a big part of, you know,
the case against sugar was, was outlining, how was used or misused.
Let's say that to be able to make the case for sugar and against fat. Um,
we'll get to that on the, uh, on the other side, in the audio version, but this,
I don't know,
I'm just speculating that the research and going down this particular rabbit
hole for years, uh, got you to better understand nutrition in general,
hence the case for Quito to your new book,
is that kind of how you arrived there?
It's about 90 clinical trials in process right now,
testing the ketogenic diet on virtually every ailment you could imagine,
because often it works very well when they do these tests on beginning with
childhood epilepsy, but, you know, obesity and diabetes. And,
uh, I mean, there are studies looking at it for depression and,
and the cognitive disorders and
you name it they're there. So anyway, that's sort of the,
my first book, good calories,
bad calories in the United States looked at all of this history and all of this
bad science and propose this idea that the problem with modern diets
because he's British nutritionist believe is the carbohydrate content of refined
grains and sugars,
which has now kind of been accepted and fat was benign.
And when you restrict the carbs and you allow people to eat fat,
now you're eating a ketogenic diet, and there's a huge movement actually,
particularly in Canada. Um,
there's a Facebook group in Canada.
I use this to sort of quantify how many physicians have bought into this.
So Facebook group in Canada of women,
physicians who eat low carb, high fat diets,
and there's about 40,000 women physicians in Canada.
And there's about 4,000 on this Facebook group,
which suggests that one in 10 women trans in Canada
alone have embraced the way of eating that until very
recently was considered virtually malpractice,
the prescribed to your patients.
Well, the case for Quito is being made. Let's say that,
and that book is available right now as of what I think a couple of days ago.
So if you are something, if,
if you're somebody that's been considering a keto diet,
or certainly somebody wants to understand just more about health and eating
highly recommend Gary's book, uh, the case for keto. Gary,
can you stick around for a few more questions?
Sure, sure. Absolutely. Okay, great. Okay.
Amazing.
If you want to hear more from investigative science journalist and bestselling
author, Gary Taubes,
click on the link below and you can listen to the full audio podcast of the
show. If you're already listening to us. Well,
we'll be back right after the break. Gary,
where can people learn more about what you're doing right now?
Uh, well, I have a website that I don't keep up.
Gary tabs.com and every time I have a new book that comes out, my
friends say, you've really got to put more information on your website.
On I tweet to Gary tau at Gary Taubes. And, uh,
those would be the two primary places and the book is available everywhere.
Fine books are sold, which is Amazon.
And as far as I can tell three bookstores that are still open.
Good one. Well,
for those of you who are ready to come along with us on this sweet ride,
some more click on the link below. And if you're done with us for today,
we'll thanks for joining us on what if discussed.